up until now an awful lot of information
security mechanisms and the policy
debate has been about the use of
security to protect the privacy of
personal data and the confidentiality of
business data but in the future once we
get software and communications in
everything is going to be much more
about safety and this is going to change
the policy debate as well because at
present many people might not object too
much to the idea that the FBI has a
golden master key that lets them break
into your iPhone and read all your
embarrassing private chat messages but I
think people will be very much more
nervous about the idea that the FBI will
have a golden master key that will
enable them to break into your car
remotely and turn it into a weapon that
could kill you and if this golden master
key is available also to other
intelligence and police agencies around
the world then perhaps that begins to
become a real problem and we have to
revisit the whole question of government
special access to cryptographic keys and
the systems in general so
have talked about the possible privacy
risks of the internet of things and we
saw the killer door being banned in
Germany because it's basically a
remotely commanda balloon bug and we
also saw the Mirai botnet last year for
some bad person recruited a couple of
hundred thousand TV cameras to DDoS a
DNS service which to Twitter offline for
a few hours in the u.s. eastern seaboard
but i think that the big problem with
the Internet of Things isn't going to be
privacy or availability is going to be
safety what we are now doing is putting
online an awful lot of devices on which
people depend for their lives which can
kill people if they go wrong the obvious
cases are cars and medical devices but
there are many more and the other thing
that's going to make this complex and
difficult is the fact that up until now
we've known how to make two kinds of
dependable system the first is a system
like our mobile forum where are you
upgraded every month to make sure that
all weak security flaws are patched but
where you're expected to throw it away
after two or three years and nobody
bothers to patch really old versions of
your forum software or your laptop
software and the other type of thing
that we build is stuff like cars and
medical devices and electricity
substations and other durable things
that we expect to last for 30 or 40
years now in the case of cars what we do
is we test the software to death before
the thing goes on sale and we hope that
it's going to be good enough and we
never upgraded afterwards unless there's
some real panic now this is going to
change because Tesla is already shipping
monthly software upgrades for their cars
Ford and BMW have already shipped some
upgrades and everybody will be doing
this within three or four years all of a
sudden your car become something like
your phone or your laptop which gets a
monthly software upgrade and this is
great for some purposes and terrible for
other purposes it's great because it
means that if there's some safety
vulnerability like for example when I
Tesla driver was killed when his car
went into the back of a truck which was
painted white because the sky was was
gray and it wasn't visible enough
something like that you can fix by
shipping a software upgrade and it will
be very very much cheaper than having to
recall millions of cars and reflashing
all the firmware at a cost of billions
and billions and billions but although
it brings us the possibility of steady
growth in vehicle safety it brings a
terrible cost with it which is that
we've got to maintain the capability to
patch that software not just for years
but for decades and we don't know how to
do that either in organizational terms
or in technical terms so let me state
the problem suppose you're working in
Cambridge England or in Cambridge
Massachusetts on some software that will
say help do navigation in a Land Rover
or a Jeep or a forum or whatever that
you expect to go on sale in 2020 how are
you going to be able to patch that
software in 2030 in 2040 there are small
numbers of systems that have been
maintained for a long time for example
deep-space probes
another example is avionics software
where basically stuff may be replaced or
make it a midlife upgrade but where
regular updates aren't expected because
the kind of devices that you have in an
airport in an airport air traffic
control system or in an aircraft
aircraft cockpit tend not to be
connected directly to the internet and
so you don't have the same attack
surface you don't suddenly have the need
to patch stuff because of shell shock or
something like that which could actually
render it open to attack but in the
future we're looking at a world in which
all our cars are online all the time
right because the car will be autonomous
or at least partly autonomous it will be
communicating
although the network had will be
downloading maps it'll be downloading
traffic information it will be
contributing to traffic information it
will be getting updates of all sorts of
kinds of cordoned data it will be a very
very complex beast and how we manage
that is going to be a big problem now at
present we have serious problems in
getting or EMS to patch systems like
Android and so most of the Android
phones in the world are insecure simply
because their vendors can't get it
together or don't have the incentives to
patch them now this is going to become
considerably worse from once we start
talking about cars because the car is
not just a simple system that's made by
one vendor anymore the the brands that
you by Volkswagen or Mercedes or Persia
or General Motors or whatever are
basically integrators who buy in
components from lots and lots of people
who sell the parts who sell the the ABS
to sell the automatic emergency braking
who sell in future the Robo chauffeur
which will actually drive you work while
you're sitting there
acting's and code and so you then got
the technical problems and the business
problems of how do you produce software
upgrades which marry together code
written by potentially dozens of
different firms then there's a question
of who's going to be liable for at all
and things go wrong and then there's
going to be the question of who pays for
at all now at present software firms try
and get rid of the liability for
software going wrong and that's not
going to be possible when software is in
devices that can kill people
legislators simply won't allow it laws
in both America and Europe and see to it
that if you sell a device that kills
people
then you reliable and it doesn't matter
how often you get your users to click on
the dog Sumi button that basically
doesn't work
for now we won't talk about exactly
what's going to see understand but the
idle hold that observations of a bottom
PP it's been very difficult yet out all
the shuttle enter but then we fight
around making difficulties all these
done them to see minute very tiny
bringing in duplication that's already
having